bootleg Kev podcast special guest in
here he just dropped a new song and
video uh make sure you go run that [__]
up man shout out to the homie
representing Chicago in the building man
Cowboy is here welcome sir
what's happening uh what's on the way
because you're dropping records you're
dropping videos I know projects on the
way we're gonna have You Freestyle then
there'll be a separate YouTube video of
our interview but before we have you do
what you gonna do man uh just plug what
you got going on man uh
my first
technically My First Independent body of
work uh Unchained on the way congrats on
being independent man just explaining
what I've been through what I've been
going through yeah you know what I'm
saying why I've been quiet for so long
we're going to explain a lot of that in
the interview which I could watch yeah
for sure but right now let's get to it
my guy brought a beat we about to have
him do what he does he says the first
time he's freestyle in a long time so
let's get to a cowboy in the building
come on
[Music]
but I survive I'm from that wild I feel
like symbol
real
okay come on let's keep it going
let's go Unchained on the wave okay
[Music]
way too easy I trap hard would they be
sleeping thinking sweet [__] we don't
demon that's why I'm leaning so
therefore that's how I'm bleeding you
won't smoke be gone next weekend trigger
finger super itchy [__] [__] give me
reasons they say I've been in that war
for tweaking out don't play with me I'm
outside with a bad [__] with me trying
to heal my scars Like A and D he won't
play that eyebrow boy might take it so
we play for keeps I can't take no wheels
a couple shells only thing you don't
take for me
[Music]
let's get it yo that was hard
Cowboy they appreciate you bro go
that was that was fire I appreciate you
guys watching this freestyle we got
another one coming and then another one
and then another one and they're all
brought to you by our good Folks at LRG
clothing you already know what it is LRG
been keeping you fly for years they got
so much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle is on the
way presented by LRG